hi everyone this is Professor M designs
and today I want to talk about the idea
of representation this is another one of
our videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
what is a representation in the familiar
euclidean space when we want to do some
mathematics with vectors we have to
represent these vectors in a particular
basis the physics of the problem is
independent of the representation that
we choose but the mathematics can be
made much simpler if we choose a good
representation an example from Euclidean
space is we have a system that looks the
same in all directions that means it has
spherical symmetry in that case we could
solve the problem using Cartesian
coordinates but the solution would be
tedious and obscure instead if we use
spherical coordinates then the solution
is transparent and simple exactly the
same happens in quantum mechanics
different representations leads to
exactly the same physics but choosing a
good representation can make the
mathematics much simpler so what is the
objective of this video I will introduce
the mathematical language of
representations in quantum mechanics so
let's go representations in quantum
mechanics are a fundamental tool because
they allow us to go from the abstract
ideas of state space to the concrete
mathematics that allows us to solve
actual quantum mechanical problems in
state space we define representation
through an orthonormal basis that spans
the full space this means that the first
question we need to ask is what is a
basis to answer this question we start
by choosing a set of cat's UI which are
orthonormal what this means is that the
bracket between UI and UJ is Delta IJ
then the set of cats u forms an
orthonormal basis if for every cat site
that belongs to the state space V there
is a unique expansion sy equal sum over
i CI u I what does this mean just like
in the familiar Euclidean vector space
we typically write vectors in a
particular basis for example the
Cartesian XY basis in state space we can
also write state in a basis in this case
the U basis the CI are the expansion
coefficients what we need to do to find
them is to first project the state psi
on the basis ket UJ we
then right outside in the UI basis we
can then move the UJ term inside the sum
and we obtain sum over I CI and then the
bracket between UJ and UI as we're
working with an orthonormal basis then
this bracket is simply Delta IJ which
means that the only term that is nonzero
in the sum is CJ so what does this mean
this is telling us that to find the
expansion coefficient C of a state's I
on a particular basis you all we have to
do is to project the state's I onto the
basis States here so let's ask again
what is a representation of a state we
can write out a cat sy in a basis u in
terms of expansion coefficient C and we
call the set of coefficients C the
representation of the cat's eye in the U
basis I already mentioned that the basis
in state space is analogous to a basis
in the familiar you clean space this is
no coincidence both state space and
Euclidean space or vector spaces with
analogous properties what I want to do
now is to make this analogy explicit
using a two dimensional Euclidean space
as an example we start by drawing the
unit vectors X hat and white hat on the
coordinate axis and these two vectors
form our basis in the two dimensional
Euclidean space these vectors form an
orthonormal basis and I am writing down
here in terms of the dot product in this
analogy the X hat Y hat basis vectors
are equivalent the UI basis cats and
these orthonormality relations are
equivalent to the bracket above giving
the auth normality condition for the you
cats we can extend our analogy to
compare the representation of vectors to
the representation of cats consider a
vector R whose component in the XY
coordinates or a and B we know that R is
equal to ax hat plus B Y hat in the XY
basis we also know that to obtain the
expansion coefficients we project the
vector R on the basis vectors so X hat
dot R gives this and then using the
orthonormality of the basis we obtain a
we can similarly obtain B by projecting
our own Y hat
what we have here is that the R vector
is analogous to the cat sign and the
expansion in the XY basis is analogous
to the expansion in the U basis now how
do we obtain the expansion coefficients
the ami coefficients are given by the
projection of the vector onto the basis
vectors calculated using the scalar or
the product by comparison the C
expansion coefficients are given by the
projection of the cat onto the basis
States and this is what the scalar
product looks like in the rack notation
going back to state space the next idea
I want to introduce is that of a closure
relation to do that we start with a cat
toy and write it down in the U basis but
this time we write the expansion
coefficient as the bracket between you
and upside rather than as the C
parameters we still remember that this
bracket is a scalar so we can move it to
the other side of the basis cats and it
allows us to rewrite the whole
expression like this to make this
rearrangement even more explicit we
write down a parenthesis around the sum
over I and we can take sci outside the
parentheses because it doesn't
explicitly depend on I the question we
can ask now is what is this parentheses
if you have seen my video on operators
you will immediately recognize this as
an operator written as now the product
so now the question becomes what does
this operator do to answer this let's
compare the cat here at the beginning
with this final expression here it looks
like the operator is doing nothing to
the cat what this means is that the
operator is the identity operator the
operator that leaves a cat invariant I
can never write the identity operator as
the sum over I of the outer product of
the basis States you this result is what
we call a closure relation or also a
resolution of the identity and in this
case it is the resolution of the
identity in the U basis before we move
on I want to remark that this is a very
important result that we will use all
the time and you will see how we use it
multiple times already in the rest of
this video now that we know how to
represent cats in a particular basis the
next question is how do we represent
brats
to answer this let's consider the braaap
site that belongs to the dual space V
star we can write the bra as equal to
psi and then the identity operator and
we can then write out the resolution of
the identity operator in the year basis
as site doesn't explicitly depend on I
we can insert it into the summation and
if we do that we obtain this expression
here we see that this is an expression
for the bra side in terms of the basis
browse you and then the expansion
coefficient are the brackets between psi
and here if we look at these expansion
coefficients we can use the conjugation
property of the scalar product to
rewrite them like this and then
comparing this expression with that of
the expansion coefficients above we can
write that C I star what is this telling
us if we have a cat sigh that we write
in the u basis in terms of the expansion
coefficient C which in turn are given by
the bracket between you and psi then we
can write the corresponding bra size in
terms of the corresponding brass you as
shown here and in this case the
expansion coefficients are the complex
conjugates of the expansion coefficients
of the cat half the cats and brass the
next thing we want is a representation
of operators remember that an operator a
is a mathematical object that acts on a
cat's eye to deliver another ket sy
prime our starting point is to write out
both sigh and sy prime cuts in the new
basis for psi we write the same
expression we have already written
multiple times and for psi prime we
write an analogous expression and we
call the expansion coefficients C prime
and they are given by the bracket
between the basis States U and the
corresponding state sy prime to figure
out what the representation of an
operator is we start by copying the
expression for CI prime we then use the
definition of sy prime as a acting on
the side then we insert the identity
operator after the a operator and then
we write down the resolution of the
identity in the u basis none of the
terms outside these parentheses depend
explicitly on J so we can move the
summation to the beginning of the
expression
and we obtained this final rearrangement
here giving some over J matrix element
of a U with respect to u I in u J and a
bracket u J website what we have here is
an expression for CI Prime that depends
on the operator a we can replace the CI
Prime above by this expression we have
just found and doing this we obtain that
Phi prime equals this long expression
here the final step is to move the UI
basis cat to the beginning and we can do
this because the other two terms are
simply scalars we can then rewrite this
whole expression like this where we can
take the PSI outside the parentheses
because it doesn't explicitly depend on
either I or J so what is this results
telling us we see that the term in
parentheses is acting on the cat's eye
and giving the cat sy Prime this is
exactly what the operator a does so the
term in parentheses is the operator a
we're done we can write an operator a in
the basis you as the sum over I J of AI
J multiplying the outer product of U I
in u J where AI J is the matrix element
of a with respect to UI and UJ what we
have here is that the numbers AI J
represent the operator a in the U basis
just like numbers C represent the cat's
eye in the U basis as an example of an
operator written in a particular basis
we can consider the resolution of the
identity which I introduced earlier we
found that we can write the identity
operator as the sum over the outer
products of all basis states the
question is is this consistent with the
representation of operators up here to
answer the question we consider the
matrix elements of the identity operator
which are UI identity operator UJ we
know that the identity operator leaves a
cat invariant so we get the bracket
between UI and UJ and it is simply Delta
IJ because of the orthonormality of the
basis putting this together the identity
operator is represented by this general
expression replacing the matrix elements
here by the expression we just found for
them here we obtain this expression
and then the Delta IJ reduces the double
sum to a single sum as shown here
comparing this result to the original
resolution of the identity we confirm
that they are the same to finish I want
to generalize representations from the
discrete basis labeled by a discrete
index I to continuous basis which are
labeled by a continuous index alpha the
generalization is pretty straightforward
and it amounts to replacing Kronecker
Delta functions of two discrete
variables with the Dirac Delta function
of two continuous variables and some of
these great indices by integrals over
continuous indices the first concept I
want to discuss is that we work with an
orthonormal basis in the continuous case
we write the of normality relation as V
alpha D beta equals the Dirac Delta
function of alpha minus beta as claimed
earlier all we're doing is replacing the
kronecker delta function with the Dirac
Delta function at this point I can
imagine that the mathematicians amongst
you will not really like this in physics
we do know that the Dirac Delta function
should only appear under the integral
sign and we really only use it under the
integral sign however it is very
convenient for discussions to write it
like this
and this is what I will do the next
concept I want to look at is the
expansion of a ket in a particular basis
we extended this to the continuous case
by writing it as an integral over the
alpha of C alpha v alpha where the
expansion coefficients now become
functions of the continuous variable and
you can see that all we do is
essentially replacing the sum over I
with an integral over alpha in this case
I will read arrive the expression for
the expansion coefficients to convince
you that we only ever use the Dirac
Delta function under an integral sign to
do that I start with the bracket between
v beta and SOI then I insert the
expansion of sy in the V alpha basis I
then rearrange the expression then I
replace the bracket between basis States
with the corresponding Delta function
and as promised the Delta function only
appears under the integral sign and
finally we can evaluate the integral to
obtain the expansion coefficient C beta
the final thing I want to look at is the
representation of an operator in a
particular basis these also generalizes
to an expression in terms of integrals
and the expansion coefficients are now
functions of two variables alpha and
beta again all we're doing is replacing
sums with integrals the reason I have
gone in some detail over this is because
both discrete and continuous bases are
important in quantum mechanics to give
you an example a much use discrete basis
is that associated with the spin of
quantum particles and the much used
continuous basis is that associated with
the position of quantum particles in
fact have probably heard about the
latter one because this is basis that
leads to the idea of wave functions in
any case you can find examples of both
these bases in action in some of my
other videos linked in the description
the wrap-up I want to ask again the
question of why do we care about
representations the physics of the
problem is independent of the
representation that we use to solve it
so the reason we care about
representations is because choosing a
good representation can rarely simplify
both the maths and the conceptual
understanding of the problem and so a
lot of the time that you will spend
solving quantum mechanical problems will
be dedicated to finding the best
representation so what have we learned
we have introduced the idea of
representations in quantum mechanics
representations are necessary for a
practical solution of quantum mechanical
problems so we're going to use them all
the time you can see how to do this in
other videos in the section what next in
the description as a teaser check out
the video on wave functions which
correspond to the position
representation of a quantum state if you
liked the video or you would like to
send me suggestions for future videos
please subscribe